j'ai dit que le monde entier rendaient
hommage aujourd'hui à jean paul sartre
ce n'est pas encore vrai en union
soviétique où la presse ne lui consacre
pas une ligne pour l'instant en revanche
aux états unis on en parle en bonne
place dans toute la presse et dans les
journaux télévisés et l'émotion est
grande dans les universités à londres la
presse dite sérieuse parle de lui comme
du sage de la gauche ou du penseur le
plus original du 20e siècle
même ton dans la presse d'allemagne
fédérale ou cependant on ne manque pas
de rappeler qu'il était allé rendre
visite aux terroristes bader dans sa
prison mais c'est peut-être au japon que
le mage est le plus grand la même les
journaux à sensation lui ont consacré la
première page le japon est le seul pays
d'ailleurs où l'on est traduit
l'intégralité de l'oeuvre de ça je vous
propose maintenant une série de
témoignages enregistrés par la rédaction
de tf1 est d'abord celui de cohn-bendit
sur mai 68
pratique impossible avant 68 de ne pas
avoir rencontré un moment ou un autre la
pensée de sartre et donc sa présence
philosophique et politique en france et
je crois que moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
touché en 68 c'est quand sartre a
demandé ma demande et que je vienne le
voir pour que lui puisse m'interviewer
je crois que si ça a été un peu pour
nous tous
ce plus ou moins inter intellectuelle le
fait qu'un père disent tout simplement
comme ça je comprends pas très bien ce
qui se passe explique - démontre quand
même là la faculté de sartre de écouté
et je crois qu'en 68
beaucoup de gens ressenti justement sa
présence avec nous en étant capable
d'écouter dans les relations vous avez
eue avec jean paul sartre qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus le plus marqué qui m'a
marqué oui disons fait il était capable
malgré les erreurs qu'ils pouvaient
faire politiquement ou la distance qu'on
pouvait avoir de garder quand même sa
solidarité
toujours du côté disons de ceux qui sont
en dehors de la société option rejetée
par la société et je crois que
fondamentalement sartre pour beaucoup de
ma génération c'est est-ce quelqu'un sur
qui on pouvait compter dans des dans les
moments où on avait besoin de quelqu'un
comme lui et que est irremplaçable
il m'avait avoué que lui sa pensée
quel que soit le lui vaut n'est que dans
l'acte de l'écriture donne au bout de la
plume la france ils devenus fous de la
pub mais comme il était devenu aveugle
il ne pouvait plus écrire et par
conséquent de la pensée ne nous venons
plus très nettement et il a fallu qu'il
mette plusieurs plusieurs années à
s'adapter à dicter à magnétophone et
encore aider avec un complice
les seuils m'a dit je vais me faire je
mets vie faire ce sera mon dernier livre
est telle qu'il a beaucoup marqué café
huile videmment je sais c'était toute ma
jeunesse ayant plus comme comme il était
toujours prêt des jeunes et près de ceux
qui avaient de l'espoir
il est pour moi si c'est une perte
considérable
évidemment il est des traditions
évidemment elle s'est trompée mais
voltaire aussi s'est trompé et diderot
s'est trompé et et bien d'autres grands
écrivains et peut-être même beaucoup de
prophètes mais faut prendre les mais
l'homme il aimait les hommes il aimait
l'humanité et ça ça un homme qui
écrivait comme ça qu'ils pensaient comme
ça et que qui aimait les hommes et la
justice à ce point là il n'y a pas
beaucoup et toujours pensé que c'était
cette époque pour nous un phare de
justice il ne s'occupait strictement pas
des recommandations de personnes il il
voyait les êtres comme il était je crois
que la grande qualité cet homme c'est
qu'il était foncièrement honnête et fou
de justice quand on m'a interdit une
pièce et au théâtre de chelles populaire
il une pièce de gatti qui sur le général
franco
il a abandonné son travail il est venu
au théâtre il m'a dit ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas juste et il a
parlé au public tous les soirs pour
expliquer pourquoi il laissait quand
même sa pièce mais que sa pièce à lui
que nous jouions à cette époque mais que
c'était une injustice totale flagrante
et qui ne supportaient pas ça ils
veulent tous les soirs au théâtre et
c'est ce qui m'a frappé et c'est ce qui
nous a tous frappés
si vous voulez et qui nous a aidés à
croire à la justice ne supportait pas la
justice